und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian sieers guten
Abend ihnen allen nachträglich gibt es
jetzt eine Notlage in Deutschland das
hat die Bundesregierung heute im
Kabinett offiziell festgestellt und zwar
mit Hinweis auf den Krieg in der Ukraine
und den damit verbundenen
energiepreisschock beides ist jetzt
nicht neu was neu ist ist die notw keit
einen rechtlich abgesicherten Haushalt
hinzubekommen nachdem das höchste
deutsche Gericht den ursprünglichen Plan
der Regierung gekippt hatte verbunden
mit der schärfstmöglichen Konsequenz
nichtig weil
verfassungswidrig jetzt wird also die
Schuldenbremse ein viertes Mal infolge
ausgesetzt am Grundproblem dass viel zu
viel Geld gebraucht wird aber viel zu
wenig Geld da ist ändert das nichts und
das mussten heute auch die
Wirtschaftsminister der Bundesländer
erfahren
frankbchwald wie weiter das fragen sich
alle in Berlin auch die giftgrünen
Demonstranten vor dem Kanzleramt ihr
Protest gegen einen autogipfel rollt
passenderweise im Auto an die riesige
öltonner Bedarf nicht runter vom
Anhänger aus Sicherheitsgründen pech für
greenpace zur gleichen Zeit im
Wirtschaftsministerium robert habck hat
seine Länderkollegen zu Gast alle haben
Sorgen ums Klima um ihre Standort und
alle wollen Geld eigentlich aus dem
klimafond kurz KTF den aber gibt es ja
nun nicht mehr wir halten alle dort
bislang über den KTF finanzierten oder
kofinanzierten Projekte für maßgeblich
zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt hier ein Ranking
zu erstellen schließt sich schlicht aus
es geht um Projekte wie dieses eine
Chipfabrik die auf einem Acker bei
Dresden entstehen soll mit Milliarden
vom Bund solche Pläne stehen nun auf der
Kippe die Länder aber
dräen da brauchen wir wirklich Zeit und
da meine ich durchaus in vielen Fällen
noch vor Weihnachten Antworten das sieht
habbeck selten Einigkeit ganz ähnlich es
geht um das grüne Prestigeprojekt und um
die Zukunft auch seine die Projekte mit
die mit dem Klima und
transformationsfond sich verbinden sie
betreffen den wirtschaftlichen Kern
Deutschlands die Konjunkturdaten sind
denke ich inzwischen in der
Öffentlichkeit bekannt habck kämpft ums
Geld woher das aber kommen soll weiß
bisher noch niemand mehr Schulden
dagegen stemmt sich die FDP ich bin sehr
sensibel wenn es um Formulierungen geht
die dazu führen die Schuldenbremse
aufzuweichen das Urteil muss man zum
Anlass nehmen um die Schuldenbremse zu
stärken die Schuldenbremse aufweichen
dazu bräuchte es eine zwei Drittel
Mehrheit die aber ist nirgends in Sicht
das weiß auch der Kanzler Scholz
schweigt heute bei der SPD Fraktion
morgen will er sich im Bundestag
erklären zu spät findet die
Opposition mit uns gibt es keine
Veränderung an der Schuldenbremse die
Ampel hat schlichtweg fertig keine Ideen
mehr und keinen Plan und es wird Zeit
dass der Bundeskanzler einen
Schlussstrich unter diese Episode Ampel
zieht einen Plan woher all das fehlende
Geld denn nun kommen soll verrät aber
auch die Union bisher nicht die Frage
wie weiter bleibt also auch heute offen
die Greenpeace Leute haben dann
wenigstens noch etwas schwarze Schmiere
aufs Pflaster tropfen lassen kein Öl nur
zuckermelasse abwaschbar man tut so als
ob das gilt ja ir wie auch für die
Politik Rubert eiwanger von den Freien
Wählern ist der vizeministerpräsident
und Wirtschaftsminister in Bayern guten
Abend Herr eiwanger ich grüße Sie alle
Projekte die wir konzipiert haben müssen
möglich gemacht werden sagt der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister heute hat
Robert Harbeck da
recht genau dasselbe habe ich auch
gesagt es sind ja eine Reihe von
Projekten aufgegleist von Wasserstoff
bis Mikroelektronik und so weiter wir
müssen die Wirtschaft in diese Richtung
transformieren und wir können jetzt
nicht zu den Investoren sagen wir
stoppen jetzt diese Dinger also das sind
ja keine frei erfundenen spaßprojekte
sondern die sind wichtig um
wettbewerbsfähig zu sein und insofern
unterstütze ich das und das war die
einhellige Meinung der Wirtschafts- und
Energieminister heute in Berlin zu sagen
wir wollen diese Projekte realisiert
sehen aber interessant ist schon dass S
jetzt so ein bisschen wieder grüne
Wirtschaftsminister und der grüne
klimaminister
klingen das ist vielleicht an der Stelle
aufgrund meiner Funktion erklärbar dass
wir einfach als Wirtschaftsminister über
alle Parteigrenzen hinweg der
Überzeugung sind wir müssen diese
Projekte realisieren der eine hat seine
mikrochipfabrik der andere will seine
Wasserstoff Pipeline das nutzt unserer
Wirtschaft unabhängig vom Parteibuch wir
müssen diese Dinge realisieren ja jeder
hat so seine Projekte für die er oder
sie Geld braucht am Ende
heißt das es ist ihn im Grunde
inhaltlich gar nicht so recht was das
höchste deutsche Gericht da geurteilt
hat aber Verfassung ist halt halt nun
mal Verfassung
äh so will ich das nicht interpretieren
es ist nun mal die Architektur dieses
finanztops falsch aufgesetzt gewesen
gleich wohl brauchen wir die Mittel für
diese Modernisierung der Wirtschaft der
Industrie aber meine politische Meinung
ist einfach dass wir an anderer Stelle
sparen sollten namentlich bei der
illegalen Migration im Bereich des
Bürgergelds für arbeitsfähige dort
müsste man Milliarden einsparen aber wir
brauchen dieses Geld für die Wirtschaft
und wenn die lampleben sagt wir sparen
im sozialen nicht ein dann müssen wir
eben zusätzliche Schulden machen damit
überhaupt noch Geld bei der Wirtschaft
ankommt aber sie wissen schon dass die
Vorschläge die sie jetzt gerade gemacht
haben nicht mal annähernd reichen um all
diese Dutzende von Milliarden Euro
aufzubringen die aktuell fehlen ja
vielleicht nicht voll aber es wäre ein
nennenswerter Beitrag also einige
Milliarden sind ja auf alle Fälle die
auf der Straße liegen und im
Migrationsbereich Milliarden die
Erhöhung des Bürgergelds kostet 4,3
Milliarden aktuell fehlen mindestens 60
Milliarden vermutlich noch viel viel
mehr bis zu 260 Milliarden in den
nächsten Jahren also das das das passt
doch alles nicht da muss doch an anderen
Stelle Geld gesucht werden wie W
büggeldmilliarden sind ja pro Jahr zu
rechnen genauso die illegale Migration
da sind wir mit Sicherheit in einem
Bereich von 10 Milliarden und mehr
unterwegs pro Jahr und die Summe die sie
jetzt genannt haben die sind ja über
mehrere Jahre verteilt also insofern ist
es durchaus ein nennenswerter
Sparbeitrag der hier geliefert werden
könnte wie wär es den mit weitaus
größten Posten im im Haushalt das ist
die Rente zur gesetzlichen Rente schießt
der Bund jedes Jahr über 100 Milliarden
zu kein anderer Posten hat so ein
Gewicht ist das auch etwas wo sie dann
sagen würden da müssen wir rangehen nein
da würde ich nicht rangehen das sind die
Leute die Deutschland aufgebaut haben
und die würden sich jetzt schön bedanken
wenn man denen jetzt die Geldbörse lehrt
für die ich wiederhol es wenn sie ja
keiner gerne hört für die illegale
Migration also erst müssen wir bei denen
hinlangen die Deutschland nicht nutzen
derzeit und müssen die Renten in Ruhe
lassen ist die Schuldenbremse denn für
diese aktuellen Zeiten jetzt mit großen
wirtschaftlichen Herausforderungen
überhaupt noch das richtige Instrument
also ich bin überzeugt dass es nächstes
J genau dieselbe Debatte wiedergeben
wird man macht ja jetzt schon die
Steuererhöhungen indem man die
gastdrsteuer nicht äh auf 7 % lässt
sondern auf 19 geht die CO2 Abgabe wird
erhöht und so weiter also insofern
werden ja schon mehr Milliarden
eingespielt und trotzdem wird es am Ende
nicht reichen also wir werden so
ehrenhaft dieser Titel ist die
Schuldenbremse auch nächstes Jahr
wiederreißen ja und ist das aus ihrer
Sicht richtig weil die Schuldenbremse in
der Art wie sie aktuell ausgestaltet ist
eigentlich nicht mehr so wahnsinnig viel
Sinn macht das war ja meine Frage
auf alle Fälle leidet Deutschland
momentan drunter dass die Wirtschaft
nicht mehr so läuft wie sie laufen
müsste aufgrund eben einer schlechten
Wettbewerbssituation in Deutschland und
deswegen ja Sprudel hier die
steuerinommen auch nicht so wie sie
sprudeln könnten und wenn wir an dieses
Problem nicht rangehen dass wir
Bürokratie reduzieren dass
wir wen das alles nicht kommt dann
wden sie haben jetzt noch keine klare
Antwort geben können bislang macht denn
die Schuldenbremse aus ihrer Sicht noch
Sinn in der Ausgestaltung wie sie im
Moment im Grundgesetz steht also ich
glaube dass wir sie nicht werden
einhalten können wenn wir auf der einen
Seite hohe Sozialausgaben uns weiterhin
leisten wollen und trotzdem die
Wirtschaft modernisieren wollen dann
werden wir die Schuldenbremse nicht
einhalten können noch mal mein Vorschlag
ist im sozialen massiv reinzugehen aber
nicht auf Kosten der Renten dann
bräuchten wir nicht so viel neues Geld
haben sie mit ihrem Ministerpräsident
mal drüber gesprochen denn der ist
deutlich klarer bei der bei der
Angelegenheit Markus Söder sagt er will
nichts ändern an dieser Schuldenbremse
und ich zitiere ihn da sind sich die
Spitzen von CSU und CDU einig ja weil
sie derzeit nicht regieren aber ich sage
ihnen voraus selbst wenn der Kanzler von
der CDU käme dann könnte er so nicht
wirtschaften auch dann müsste er
entweder massiv im Sozialbereich
Einschnitte tätigen oder er müsste neues
Geld aufnehmen ganz wichtiges anderes
Thema ist heute noch die Autoindustrie
die jetzt Alarm schlägt die Marke VW sei
mit den bisherigen Strukturen Prozessen
und hohen Kosten nicht mehr
wettbewerbsfähig das sagt
interessanterweise der VW Markenchef
selbst wie ernst nehmen Sie das als
Wirtschaftsminister des autolandes
Bayern sehr ernst und ich bin überzeugt
dass es ein massiv strategischer Fehler
ist dass Deutschland sagt ab 2030 wollen
wir keine verbrennerautos mehr zulassen
wir werden noch berohen dass wir den
Verbrenner jetzt kaputt machen und
kommen bei der Elektromobilität nicht so
richtig voran wenn derzeit 1 Million von
48 Millionen Autos in Deutschland reine
E-Mobile sind und wir wollen 15
Millionen bis 2030 hinkriegen das
kriegen wir nicht hin die Chinesen
werden den Markt aufrollen und werden
die deutschen verdrängen wenn wir
weiterhin eine solche Amokfahrt hier
machen in der autopolitik sagt der
bayerische Wirtschaftsminister Hubert
eiwanger Herr eiwanger vielen Dank ich
danke Ihnen und das Interview haben wir
aus Termingründen vor knapp zwei Stunden
aufgezeichnet der bayerische
Wirtschaftsminister hätte also weiter
wie gerade gehört auf den
Verbrennermotor gesetzt wie stellt sich
denn die Bundesregierung vor wie es
jetzt in der mobilitätsfrage endlich
vorangehen soll das war ja Hanna heute
großes Thema in Berlin ja denn allen
Beteiligten ist klar der Ausbau der
Elektromobilität geht bei weitem nicht
so schnell voran wie geplant all das war
heute Thema beim autogipfel im
Bundeskanzleramt unter anderem mit
Vertretern der
Automobilindustrie Frank betetmann die
große Frage ist also wie die gesteckten
Ziele überhaupt erreicht werden sollen
was ist bei dem Gipfel herausgekommen ja
nicht mehr als Absichtserklärungen man
sei sich einig dass es mehr Ladesäulen
braucht und vor allem dass die E-Autos
deutlich billiger werden müssten der
ADAC hatte erst jüngst bemängelt dass es
überhaupt nur drei Modelle gebe die
derzeit lautliste weniger als 30.000 €
kosten würde man hat heute auf dem
Gipfel den verbalen Schulterschluss
gesucht verständlich denn mit aktuell
1,3 Millionen reinen Elektrofahrzeugen
auf deutschlandstraßen und rund 100.000
Ladepunkten ist man immer noch weit von
den angestrebten Zielen entfernt es
braucht also gemeinsame Anstrengung aber
wie realistisch ist die Umsetzung Tesla
oder VW die heute mit am Tisch saßen
haben günstigere E-Autos kündigt aber
voraussichtlich nicht vor 2026 ein
weiteres großes Problem mehr Ladesäulen
vor allen in großstätdten auch dazu
heute keine konkreten Antworten ja es
ging heute auch ums Geld um die
e-autoförderung gab's dazu irgendwelche
neuen Erkenntnisse nein darüber so ein
Teilnehmer wurde heute gar nicht
gesprochen dabei ist das der wichtigste
Punkt können die Autobauer können die
Zulieferer auch die potenziellen Kunden
weiterhin mit Fördergeldern rechnen oder
eben nicht es besteht weiterhin großer
Klärungsbedarf deswegen muss man heute
abend sagen nach dem Gipfel ist vor dem
nächsten Gipfel vielen Dank Frank für
deine
Einschätzung wenn in Zukunft immer mehr
Wärmepumpen und E-Autos strombenötigen
könnte dadurch zeitweise das Stromnetz
überlastet werden deshalb hat die
Bundesnetzagentur ab Januar neue Regeln
festgelegt droht eine Überlastung dürfen
Netzbetreiber den Strombezug von neuen
steuerbaren Wärmepumpen oder
Ladestationen temporär einschränken eine
Mindestleistung stehe aber immer zur
Verfügung die Geräte können also
weiterlaufen oder E-Autos langsamer
geladen werden im Gegenzug soll es
Ermäßigungen
geben das Gesetz zur Legalisierung von
Cannabis soll weniger streng ausfallen
als bisher geplant darauf haben sich die
ampelfraktionen geeinigt beim Eigenanbau
soll künftig der Besitz von 50 g
Cannabis erlaubt sein das ist doppelt so
viel wie im bisherigen Gesetzentwurf die
Fraktionen verständigten sich außerdem
darauf das konsumverbot von Cannabis in
der Nähe von Schulen zu lockern der
Umkreis wurde von 200 m auf 100
reduziert das cannabisgesetz soll im
kommenden Jahr in Kraft
treten bei einem Treffen in ungarn hat
bundesinnenministerin fäa eine engere
Zusammenarbeit mit den Ost und
mitteleuropäischen Ländern angekündigt
um irreguläre Migration zu begrenzen mit
ihren Amts Kollegen aus Tschechien
Ungarn Österreich Polen und der Slowakei
vereinbarte Sie dazu einen regelmäßigen
Datenaustausch zwischen den
Grenzbehörden zudem mnte fäer eine
baldige Umsetzung der euasylreform
an zwei weitere Tage Feuerpause nach
über 7 Wochen Krieg allein das ist
bereits eine Nachricht heute aus Nahost
und es gibt neue Hoffnung dass weitere
Geiseln freikommen aus der Hand der
hammas es gibt neue Gelegenheit um das
Leid der Zivilbevölkerung in Gaza
überhaupt zu begreifen für
hunderttausende Menschen ist völlig
offen wie und wo sie leben sollen es ist
wirklich kaum vorstellbar auf beiden
Seiten manche der jetzt freigelassenen
Geiseln wissen noch gar nicht dass ihre
Männer oder Kinder von Hamas ermordet
wurden ein 25jähriger hatte offenbar
seinen Bewachern entkommen können und
war vier Tage lang durch Gaza geirrt
bevor er von der Hamas wieder gefangen
genommen wurde und im Norden von Gaza
flächendeckende Zerstörung und unter den
Trümmern befinden sich unzählige weitere
Leichen nach UNO berichten sollen
Menschen inzwischen Türen und
Fensterrahmen anzünden damit sie kochen
können luten leinus
berichtet ihre Welt ist noch kleiner
geworden im engen Gasastreifen rund 2
Millionen Menschen sind im Süden
zusammengepfercht sie stehen an für Gas
und Mehl der Waffenstillstand hat wenig
Linderung gebracht noch immer gibt es
von allem zu
wenig wir können nur einmal am Tag Tee
trinken weil kein Gas da ist die Kinder
gehen hungrig zu Bett es gibt kaum
Brot ich hoffe dass die Feuerpause
verlängert wird die Menschen zur Ruhe
kommen und die Situation sich
verbessert die gute Nachricht der
Vermittler aus Qatar kommt am Abend die
Feuerpause wird um zwei Tage verlängert
Stunden später übergibt die Hamas
weitere israelische Geiseln an das Rote
Kreuz darunter sollen laut Qatar zwei
deutsche sein israel hat der Feuerpause
erst spät zugestimmt das hat seinen
Grund sagen Experten die Regierung
stecke in einem
Dilemma einerseits geht es um die
Geiseln andererseits gefährdet es unsere
Soldaten in Gaza und es birgt die Gefahr
dass der internationale Druck auf Israel
wächst den Krieg zu stoppen und einem
Waffenstillstand zuzustimmen was Israels
Ziel die Hamas zu zerstören komplett
entgegensteht
die israelische Gesellschaft ist in
dieser Frage tief gespalten mehr als 160
geisenn sind noch in der Hand der Hamas
für die Angehörigen ist die Sache klar
für harliner und die Armee
weniger die Feuerpause soll ausgeweitet
werden wir wollen dass alle nach Hause
kommen was auch immer dafür verlangt
wird wir haben die Pflicht die Geiseln
nach Hause zu bringen entweder auf
diplomatischenem Weg des Austausches
oder in der nächsten Phase des Krieges
vorerst hält die Feuerpause und mit ihr
die Hoffnung dass weitere Geiseln
freikommen der deutsche Bundespräsident
besuchte heute das von Hamas Terroristen
weitgehend zerstörte kibutzberli es
wurde einst von deutschen Juden
mitbegründet und liegt in unmittelbarer
Nähe zum
Gazastreifen wir haben die Bilder im
Fernsehen gesehen und es war leicht sich
vorzustellen was hier geschehen ist ist
aber selbst hier zu sein genau an diesem
Platz ist etwas
anderes mehr als 130 Bewohner des kibuts
wurden hier am 7 Oktober umgebracht
darunter auch Vivian silver eine
44-jährige
Friedensaktivistin sie fuhr einmal die
Woche nach Gaza um kranke Frauen und
Kinder in israelische Krankenhäuser zu
bringen wir brauchten einen Monat lang
um Sie zu identifizieren es war nichts
mehr von ihr
übrig
den Wiederaufbau des kibuts wird
Deutschland mit 7 Millionen Euro
unterstützen diese Zusage hatte
Steinmeier mit nach beri
gebracht wir gehen noch mal live nach
telaviv zu Michael beverung guten
Michael die Feuerpause soll jetzt also
verlängert werden da stellt sich
natürlich die Frage kann das
möglicherweise der Anfang vom Ende des
Krieges sein oder ist das einfach viel
zu optimistisch
gedacht
ich glaube dass das sehr optimistisch
ist aber das scheint zumindest das Ziel
der Hamas zu sein eben diese Feuerpause
immer weiter auszudehnen heute gab es
eine Meldung dass die Hamas angeblich
jetzt auch über die gefangenen Soldaten
sprechen will der Preis für sie wäre
wahrscheinlich noch viel höher das Ziel
ist klar diese Feuerpause so lange zu
verlängern dass sie dann irgendwann in
einen dauerhaften Waffenstillstand
übergeht ich denke aber dass die
Regierung tatsächlich ein anderes Ziel
hat hat nämlich dauerhaft tatsächlich
die Hamas zu zerstören und die Kampagne
auch im Süden fortzusetzen es ist
allerdings die Frage was sich da am Ende
durchsetzen wird sagt Michael beverunge
in telaviv Michael herzlichen Dank für
diese Einschätzung heute Abend der Krieg
ist längst auch ein Informationskrieg
geworden wobei das Wort Information
eigentlich nicht passt es ist auch ein
desinformationskrieg um die öffentliche
Meinung in aller Welt und damit spielt
sich dieser Teil des nordostkonflikts
auch in Deutschland ab unter uns und
besonders bei den jungen Menschen in
Deutschland die Julia Heldt und Michael
haselrieder getroffen
haben das Jugendzentrum Arche im Osten
Berlins die Mehrheit der Kinder und
Jugendlichen stammt aus muslimischen
Familien der Angriff der Hamas und der G
Gazakrieg haben die Atmosphäre hier
verändert wie weit das geht hat wolfgang
Büscher selbst zu spüren bekommen als er
eine israelische Flagge am rev
trug ein kleiner Junge so ungefähr 11
Jahre alt
sagte mir plötzlich du Wolfgang ich
hasse dich mein Opa kommt aus Palästina
und die Juden haben uns unser Land
wegggenommen und wir hassen alle Juden
also seit dem 7 oktober hat sich das
Ganze noch mal
verschärft solchen radikalen Gedanken
versuchen sie in der Arche etwas
entgegenzusetzen sie wollen
Antisemitismus bekämpfen und liberale
Werte vermitteln denn viele Kinder und
Jugendliche kennen aus ihren Familien
und den sozialen Medien oft nur
Seite seitdem der Krieg Gefahrt ist
automatisch nur gekommen ich kann ih
sagen dass jetzt über
so z 300 Videos über ver gesehen habe wo
die Leute sterben die Kinder würden mit
diesen Bildern zu oft alleinelassen
kritisiert wolfgang Büscher und fordert
auch von den Schulen mehr Engagement oft
scrollen Sie dann nachmittags auf tiktok
hören noch mal radikale Äußerung das
heißt diese Kinder werden 24 Stunden am
Tag radikalisiert da sind wir als
private Organisation als Arche auch ein
bisschen überfordern wir brauchen ja
einfach die Unterstützung auch vom
System diese Hamburger
Gemeinschaftsschule ist da noch eine
Ausnahme mit einem Rollenspiel will die
Lehrerin ihre Schüler sensibilisieren
jeder vertritt einen der Akteure im
Nahostkonflikt sie sich ich begrüße Sie
zu unseren Friedensverhandlungen seit
dem 7 oktober hat sich die Lage
dramatisch zugespit % der Kinder sind
muslimisch der Krieg ist für sie ein
emotionales Thema viele wollen deshalb
nicht erkannt werden die Sorge der
Lehrer über Youtube und tiktok erreichen
auch radikale Prediger die Jugendlichen
meine Befürchtung ist auch dass Schüler
die sich eigentlich vor gar nicht so mit
Politik beschäftigt haben jetzt in
diesen stuhel mit reingezogen werden
auch durch die
Medien die ungefiltert teilweise
angeschaut werden da versuchen wir ja im
Prinzip mit umzugehen auch dass da
natürlich Hass geschürt wird deshalb
denke ich auch die Hamas hat wirklich
ihr Ziel erreicht ja dass also
tatsächlich Antisemitismus wieder
geschürt worden ist auch in der Arche
diskutieren sie offen über den Konflikt
das kann oft hart sein erlebt
archegründer Bern siegelko dieser
13-jährige Junge sieht Israel als
Aggressor und zeigt Verständnis für den
hamasangriff israel hat immer mehr
angegriffen hat immer mehr erobert und
jetzt wollen die halt wieder
zurück sie wollen jetzt ihr Land wieder
zurückholen indem sie Kinder umbringen
und Frauen aber Israel hat es doch auch
gemacht die haben einfach getötet den
unterschiedlichen Perspektiven Raum
geben einordnen aber auch Grenzen setzen
wie wichtig das ist wissen sie in der
Arche und hoffen dass solche Orte nicht
die Ausnahme
bleiben so jetzt bei uns hier in der
Sendung noch mal du Hanna mit ein Blick
aufs Wetter ganz genau ein heftiger
Wintersturm hat die ukrainische
Schwarzmeerküste die von Russland
illegal annektierte Halbinsel Krim und
den Süden Russlands getroffen besonders
die Region um soi mit
Windgeschwindigkeiten von mehr als 140
km pro Stunde ließ der Sturm Meter hohe
Wellen an die Strände donnern mindestens
zwei Menschen starben dort fast 2
Millionen waren nach russischen Angaben
ohne Strom in Odessa stürzte der
Schornstein eines Heizkraftwerks ein
auch dort waren Hunderttausende von der
Stromversorgung
abgeschnitten winterliches Wetter hat
auch viele Regionen in Deutschland fest
im Griff für Teile von Hessen und
reheinandpfalz warnt der deutsche
Wetterdienst oberhalb von 400 m vor
starkem Schneefall und Glätte bereits am
Wochenende hatten Glatteis und Schnee
für Unfälle gesorgt und auch die neue
Woche begann mit Schneefällen und
glatten Straßen auf einer Bundesstraße
nahe koblen starb eine Frau nachdem sie
in den Gegenverkehr gekommen war ein
Mann wurde schwer verletzt vor allem LKW
kämpften mit dem Schnee blockierten
Ausfahrten oder rutschten in Gräben
mehrere Personen wurden auch hier
verletzt das Solidaritätskonzert in
Berlin heute Abend war innerhalb von
viereinhalb Minuten ausverkauft 700
Menschen im Saal des Berliner Ensemble
wollten nicht schweigen sie wollen laut
sein gegen Antisemitismus sie wollen ein
Zeichen setzen Deutschland fängt an zu
zerreißen so nimmt der Intendant des
Theaters die derzeitige Stimmung hier
bei uns wahr aber er macht Hoffnung
Theater kann eine ganze Menge ausrichten
vor allen Dingen dann wenn man es
hautnah erlebt chr leler nimmt uns
mit manche Dinge dauern länger das
wusste Bert Brecht nur zu genau eine
Welt ohne Kriege das wäre ein
Fortschritt doch unsere Zeit ist voller
Hass Antisemitismus und Schweigen
gemeinsam die Stimme erheben darum geht
es an diesem
[Musik]
Amt der Pianist Igor let hat gerufen und
viele sind dem deutschrussischen Musiker
gefolgt heute Abend werden keine Reden
gehalten keine Politiker auf der Bühne
es werden keine Statements verlesen es
ist eine ganz klare Haltung bei jeder
und bei jedem
erkennbar alleine weil sie heute hier
sind 7 Wochen nach dem hamasüberfall
herrschte ein langes Schweigen im
Kulturbetrieb jetzt zeigen sich
Prominente sie sagen es seit Zeit die
Stimme zu erheben es gebe eine deutsche
Verantwortung für die Juden Stars von
Katharina Talbach bis Maria Schrader von
Wolf Biermann bis zu
Campino das ist ein unerträglicher
Gedanke dass all diese Menschen Angst
haben Angst haben ihre Kinder in die
Kitter zu bringen oder zur Schule Angst
haben ihre Religion hier frei ausleben
zu können dafür haben wir alle mal haben
unsere Eltern teilweise Großeltern auch
schon gerufen nie wieder und in diesen
Schuhen wollen wir stehen ich will meine
eigenen Eltern nicht
verraten gustaver wo die schönen
Trompeten blasen gegen den Ungeist gegen
Terror Ausgrenzung und Verzweiflung der
Abend will Mut machen jeder Einzelne
könne etwas tun heißt es wegschauen gehe
nicht ein Höhepunkt der Auftritt der
102jährigen Margot friedlender eine
Berliner Holocaust Überlebende ich bin
entsetzt was
jetzt sich aufgetan hat nach einer neuen
Umfrage sieht nur jeder dritte Deutsche
eine historische Verantwort für Israel
doch der Riss geht tiefer auch die
Jungen von FR for future sind gespalten
keta Thunberg gibt sich
proalästinensisch Luisa Neubauer
appelliert für mehr Mitgefühl für die
hamasopfer ich stehe hier
und werbe dafür und kämpfe dafür und
streite dafür dass
wir die die Menschlichkeit in uns und um
uns nicht verlieren und vergessen und
dass wir uns nicht zu unangemessenen
Einseitigkeit hinreißen lassen der Abend
im Berliner Ensemble zeigt es gibt ein
großes Bedürfnis nach Trost nach
Austausch und
[Musik]
Orientierung Musik kann und hat die
Macht
an Gefühle zu appellieren an die häufig
auch Worte nicht drankommen die Welt
retten kann sie nicht das ist an uns SLE
nachdenkliche Töne an diesem Berliner
Abend sie wurden so lange
vermisst und das war unser Montag für
Sie im heutejournal kurz vor mitittnach
meldet sich dann hier Christopher
wermann mit unserem heutejournal Update
von uns Seen ein angenehmen Abend
tschüss
[Musik]
schön guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter einiges an Schnee
ist heute gefallen und das lag an einem
Tief was in der Nacht bereits im
Nordwesten lag und allmählich in unsere
Richtung gezogen ist jetzt ist es etwa
über der Mitte und wird nach Südosten
hin abziehen dahinter lockert es schon
wieder auf aber Schauer sind dabei und
meist in schneeform schauen wir auf die
Nacht unterschneit es erst einmal bis in
tiefe en hier ist natürlich Glätte
inklusive im Süden ist auch Regen dabei
von Norden her lockert es allmählich auf
die tiefsten Temperaturen nach
nordostenen bei -3° nach südwestenen +
5° aber s sehen hier vor allem der
nordhäfte häufig Temperaturen unter der
0°ad Marke hier also frostig kalt ja und
morgen dann weiterer Schnee in der Mitte
es verlagert sich Richtung Süden dort
regnet es ganz am Alpenrand Schneid es
von Norden her lockert es auf Richtung
Ostsee ebenfalls Schneeflocken dabei die
Temperaturen erreichen höchste Werte von
-1° nur das sind tatsächlich die
Höchstwerte es bleibt also bei dauerf
Frost nach Nordosten hin um die 0° Marke
ja und im Südwesten ist es deutlich
milder + 6° werden hier erreicht die
nächsten Tage weiterer Regen und Schnee
folgt vor allem nach Norden hin eisig
kalt -2 bis + 5° die höchsten Werte
Dienstag dann weiterer Schnee vor allem
im Süden und auch am Freitag kalt
Temperaturen -2 bis + 6° und damit einen
schönen
Abend